but
41-28 was the final score on sunday in
foxboro and the game was not nearly that
close garbage time galore points for the
la chargers they were down 35-7
at the end of the first half the
patriots taking full advantage of the
bye week full advantage of playoff
experience chris i've been saying this
for weeks
when you come into the preparation for
the game when you have guys in the
locker room who have been there but
brady 38 postseason games insane bill
belichick 40 as a head coach
you you
you make it so much easier for your
players to understand what to expect
what to expect they have faith in the
process right and they know if they
listen to what they're being told both
by belichick and by brady it's all going
to work out because they've been there
time and time and time again you're
right the the patriots players can look
at two of their leaders and go okay
they've been here they've done that
they're very calm you know their fact
that they're calm and you know uh
attention to detail it rubs off on the
rest of the football team you know when
the offensive line and the rest of the
offensive group sees the quarterback
that's unflappable and calm and a big
week in every moment they start to go
okay i mean things are good our
quarterback feels good i mean it rubs
off on the rest of the football team so
you're exactly right that experience
comes back to help them so much and you
know to the game yesterday
their experience against that defensive
scheme is what killed the los angeles
chargers you know having them then
played that seattle scheme which gus
bradley came from seattle and really was
the architect of that great seattle's uh
pete carroll defense that that was in
two super bowls gus bradley is really
the guy who kind of tinkered with that
and invented it well new england's got a
great experience of that because they
got two weeks to prepare for that on
super bowl 59 and two weeks ago to
prepare for it in super bowl 51 against
the atlanta falcons and i think between
that their preparation for that and then
the chargers lack of size on the
defensive line we saw the patriots run
the ball run the ball oh oh and then
they're not afraid to get in third and
short and you know stats goes where's
boso where's ingram well when you're
running the ball and then it's third and
three or third and four and brady
doesn't have to sit there and wait for
people to get down the field because
it's third and long he can get the ball
out of his hands and they can design a
quick little throw to get the third and
three and third and four to get the
first down boson and ingram become you
know they don't become a part of the
football game and i think that's what we
saw yesterday
yeah and and uh
you know for the charters
i don't know what's better i we kind of
touched on this last hour i think you're
right is it better is it better to go
into the next season just getting
splattered and being reminded you got a
long way to go or to have it so close
where you think you're going to beat the
patriots and lose and get thrust back
down to zero and zero and have to
rebuild it's a long off season when you
end it that way but i i think the
chargers can look in the mirror and say
here's what we need to do if we want to
be like the patriots and we're getting
there but but we need to make some
improvements we need to make some
adjustments and they also need to be
thinking about their next quarterback i
don't know how many more of these rodeos
philip rivers is going to have and
that's going to be the biggest question
and then how do you do that transition
we obsess over what the giants are going
to do with eli manning at what point do
we start to look at the charges and say
what are you guys going to do after
philip rivers yeah well i think they
wanted to draft to sean watson a few
years ago i mean everything i know
around the nfl they were very interested
in deshawn watson and i don't think i
think they realized that phillip rivers
wasn't all that happy about that talk it
was the year they were moving to l.a and
they backed off about it backed off it a
little bit i really think that's the big
issue but yes it's getting towards that
time i mean you saw yesterday phillip
rivers he's got to throw everything he's
got to throw it 40 yards down the field
and the patriots defenders they were up
in the face of the chargers wide
receivers all game long and i think one
they weren't necessarily afraid of some
of the speed on the field from the
chargers at the wide receiver's position
two they weren't necessarily afraid of
phillip rivers arm down the field to
expose them too much but you know to
your point mike i think it's a good
point about is it better to lose a close
one or get splattered i'll use last
year's i think it's better to get
splattered because it first of all you
can swallow that loss like we weren't
the better team we got beat and we need
to improve our football team you keep it
close you might go dancing down
jacksonville jaguar way like what they
did last year well we don't really need
to make any adjustments to our team we
were really close we should be back
there again and maybe that complacency
can sit in so you know set in there a
little bit um but yeah either way they
were outclassed the chargers yesterday
by a fresh healthy new england patriots
team that had the proper scheme on both
sides of the ball to like you said just
dominate the football game the final
score really doesn't tell the story
you know you mentioned the flirtation
with desean watson it was two years
before that they were looking at marcus
mariota if you remember that they
brought him in for for a visit a workout
they they looked very closely at him
there was talk of maybe they would trade
phillip rivers to the titans he'd be
close to the area where he grew up and
he'd finish his career in tennessee and
the the uh chargers would end up with
mariota and that obviously never came to
be but it's been and maybe the chargers
benefit from the fact that they're not a
national brand that people obsess over
because that would have been huge drama
and it was a it was a fairly big deal at
the time but if you make that something
that's happening in new york with the
giants or you know a bigger team
uh that's something that's hard to get
past and philip rivers has dealt with a
lot and i think it's his love of the
game that gets him to keep coming back
the question is how many more years will
he come back and at what point do you
see the chargers use that first round
pick on the next phillip rivers the
successor to him they weren't bashful
about doing it when they had drew brees
on the team now that wasn't the same
drew brees we've seen since then but
they drafted philip rivers well they
drafted eli manning and traded him for
phillip rivers at a time when they had
breeze so they have to make that
decision you don't want to wait too long
and go through a year or two where
you're just lost in the wilderness
because you don't have a good
quarterback yeah no no you're exactly
right and i mean i think those questions
about uh the quarterback issue and what
they're going to do going forward
certainly they're going to be thinking
about them this off season because the
other thing too and again phillip rivers
is phenomenal and he had a great year
and and you know he's a borderline hall
of famer certainly but what the what the
patriots did yesterday with not only
getting in the receivers faces like i
talked about because jc jackson and
stefan gilmour i mean the the patriots
have the best secondary uh they had the
best secondary left in the playoffs in
the divisional round and they still got
the best secondary left now that it's
the final four but this jc jackson this
rookie number 27 for the fans out there
he's a special player he was an
undrafted free agent who had gotten in
trouble at the university of miami and
then had a transfer to maryland and
that's really why he was undrafted but
he was really a top 60 player in the
draft and then stephon gilmore on the
other side who you could argue is really
one of the best corners in football with
devin mccourty who i would say is in the
convo for one of the best free safeties
in football their ability to match up
and play man-to-man against those
chargers wide receivers and then the
other thing we saw is the patriots not
afraid to send a little pressure philip
rivers way why because they knew philip
rivers ain't running anywhere he's not
going to escape the pocket and i think
those two things there
were you know a little bit on phillip
rivers and the fact that he is what is
he 38 39 years old uh
and he can't do some of the things that
he used to be able to do
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports